the most promising thing that I have
seen is this Research into psychedelic
therapy-assisted psychedelic does that
make sense to you that psychedelics work
so well for such difficult cases what
what is it about psychedelics and I've
been following This research from the
beginning when they were doing end of
life yeah they started with end-of-life
patients I don't know maybe 20 years ago
I met at its head conference I met one
of the doctors who was
who was doing this research was the
first time I became aware that the
research was happening and I'd already
had my own experiences before that and
so it made perfect sense to me that this
would work it was still astonishing to
see the results to see how successful
um the work is so much of the time but
it doesn't surprise me it makes sense
and it's actually in line with all these
other things so quieting down
the default mode Network
one of the things that's so
transformative about taking something
like psilocybin and everyone's
experience is different it can vary each
time you take it even in a single person
but
the experience I had and the experience
that many people have that is so
transformative is this feeling that's
very hard to describe but it's a feeling
of being one with the universe and that
comes with it's kind of all one feeling
that that is again hard to put into
words but there's this feeling that
everything is okay
um and I'd never had that feeling before
in my life and when I took psychedelics
that feeling would stay with me for
months and I never understood why and it
was always fascinating to me but there
was it was as if I was glimpsing a
deeper truth of the world that
it's all one thing we're all connected
um there's
no sense that there could even be a
feeling of loneliness it was just this
visceral sense of being one with
everything and that everything was okay
that all the things I was afraid of even
death
um
that the Universe in a sense is just is
is an endless Recycling and
I don't know it's hard to describe but
we also know on the other side that
depression and anxiety
in when people are experiencing those
things the default mode network is is
more active yeah and so it's this this
cycling and this kind of obsessive
cycles of thinking about one's self that
is a huge part of the suffering in the
first place and so
the one thing that's surprising to me
about the research is that
um I I may be fudging the the data but
it's something like 80 of people who are
treated for PTSD after one
only one session are
cured of their pts yeah the the effect
stays for prolonged periods of time yeah
that's really interesting an addiction
as well which is interesting that's not
something I'm like personally personally
familiar with so that was a surprise to
me but yeah I mean it's just wonderful
that we
yeah it's incredible I mean of course
it's also incredible for people who
don't uh suffer to see what psychedelics
can do with the mind which is that kind
of appreciation well and I think it's
actually important for this work it's
one of the questions I ask everyone I
talk to
for this series
um many of them you know I won't be able
to use that Audio Oh ask for a lot of
them yes and what their experience was
and if that's informed you know actually
initially in the 50s I want to do more
research on this and look into it but in
the 50s there were some studies that
were being done with Scientists who
there were hundreds of scientists they
put into the study
um where they were on the brink of some
kind of Discovery some where they were
stuck so they had been doing research
and they were stuck and they used
psychedelics to come up with an answer
to find a path forward and it was
extremely useful for that yeah I mean
it's fascinating and the nice thing
about psychedelics for my perception is
that they don't currently suffer from
the taboo that weed does
I don't think so like um for example
there's some kind of uh cultural
construct about a pothead
that makes it so that you know like Elon
got in trouble for smoking weed right he
would have gotten in trouble for taking
mushrooms too I don't know really I
don't think so oh that's interesting I
don't think that's a surprise to me
because mushrooms mushrooms to me seem
like a journey like there's a perception
that you don't take mushrooms all the
time it's not an addictive substance
it's not a lifestyle it's uh it's like
going to burning man it's like a
experience that stays with you for a
long time didn't realize that
understanding had permeated into the
culture yeah that's a good question of
how uh if it has or not because maybe I
have a very narrow perspective these
kinds of things but I think what has
permeated is through Hollywood ideas of
what it means to be a person who smokes
weed a lot yeah and that and that has
like has it has had its effect which is
hilarious given
the the effects of weed versus alcohol
but that's a whole nother story
and you've spoken about podcasts yeah
yeah so not not a lot I mean I really
want to do a lot more I've taken uh
mushrooms aspirations yeah I mean
because
and I didn't didn't have I have a very
addictive personality so I'm very
nervous about substances but I didn't
have any addictive relationship with
that yeah I think well every time I it
is a treatment for addiction so
interesting but
uh I you know I'm almost nervous because
every time I've I've taken mushrooms
I've had a really pleasant experience I
mean it was um
it's already the thing I feel anyway
yeah but I feel it more intensely the
thing I feel anyways like appreciation
of the moment how beautiful life is the
weird thing
that I feel not throughout the day but
certain moments of the day especially
early on that's like life
is intensely beautiful
like
um that's usually what I'll tweet yeah
it's like Everything is Everything is
awesome and I I remember those feelings
because sometimes when I feel really
down and all those kinds of things you
remember that like it's a roller coaster
and you just and then you find the good
feelings and it's cool and it does make
me a little bit sad that they kind of
fade but then as they get older you get
to use those moments you realize they
don't use them well you know because
when you feel great when you're focused
all that kind of stuff use them well
yeah because the mind is a roller
coaster yes it's true that's partly why
I do this work I feel like my work is
therapy I don't know if you feel that
way work is therapy this work not work
in general
thinking about the Deep questions
thinking about the nature of the
universe
um thinking about Consciousness even
meditation I mean I got into meditation
to me it's interesting to me I mean it's
I think a lot of meditators feel feel
this way about it but I think just I'm
thinking about it from the perspective
of someone who hasn't meditated before
but it feels like a scientific
experiment it feels like it's the same
physicist in me
um who was drawn to meditation because
the experience is one of
getting closer to your experience and
asking similarly deep questions like
what is time what does that even mean
what what do I mean by time what does it
feel like
um what is a thought is one of the most
interesting questions to me